Gwyneth Paltrow looking like a Golden
Goddess ringing in the big 5-0 in her
birthday suit and it was pretty crazy
the actress commemorates her 50th
birthday by posing nude her Lifestyle
brand goop released the pics the
inspiration Goldfinger the 1964 James
Bond film
the girl's dead
Masters Jill Masterson
is covered in paint gold paint check out
Gwen dripping in Gold flaunting her fit
physique but the Iron Man Star says her
team kept her kinda in the dark
explaining quote all I know is that
they're painting me gold and that I have
to be naked I feel so good turning 50
and this is about expressing that sense
of energy and optimism that I'm
experiencing it's more about the female
gays and just a sense of fun it's a good
combination sexiness intelligence you
know that's that's sort of the goal I
think now Goins no stranger to a sexy
birthday shoot she did something similar
when she turned 48. I think that when um
you know you know yourself well and you
you've lived a life with lots of ups and
downs and you get to be in your 40s I
think you feel pretty good all the time
yeah there's Gwyneth posing in the buff
outdoors with the biggest smile but uh
those snaps didn't exactly impress her
then 16 year old daughter Apple Apple oh
my God yes Apple summed up how she felt
about it in an Instagram comment one
word Mom I don't feel pressure to look
young I feel like I've earned my
wrinkles and I'm very proud of you know
everything that I've gone through in my
life both good and bad Flash Forward a
few years and Gwen's feeling the same
about turning 50. in a love letter to
her body she writes quote my body a map
of the evidence of all the days is less
Timeless and while I do what I can to
strive for Good Health and Longevity to
Stave off weakening muscles and receding
bone I have a mantra I insert into those
Reckless thoughts that try to derail me
I accept yeah the stretch marks the
loose skin the wrinkles Gwyneth says
she's down for it all quote I accept my
body and let go of the need to be
perfect
foreign